[MUSIC PLAYING]
- All right.
So today I'm here to talk
about Learning Deeply at Scale:
the Challenge of our Times.
So this comes out of a
five-year research project
that my doctoral colleague
at the ed school, Sarah Fine,
and I have been conducting.
It's a study of
ambitious instruction--
instruction which is rigorous,
challenging, engaging--
in American high schools.
We did essentially a sort
of tour, a national tour,
of American high schools--
comprehensive schools, public
schools, charter schools,
those no excuses
schools you read
about in the paper,
project-based schools, schools
that do international
baccalaureate,
schools that do AP, schools
that are rich, poor, et cetera.
To just sort of get
a sense, as Judy
said, in a sort of broad
sense of what does instruction
in high schools look like?
Where is it better?
What can we do about it?
We oversampled schools
serving poor and working
class students, but this is a
book about schools as a whole.
There are a lot of middle class,
affluent schools in our book
and in our writing.
Our methods were mainly to
observe and to talk to people.
We spent a lot of time
in classes and meetings,
on fields, in theaters.
And we interviewed
a lot of folks.
And there is a book, thanks
in no part to all the time
I had at Radcliffe this year,
coming out on this next year.
OK.
So just provisionally, we'll be
talking about deeper learning.
So let me just give you this
definition from Hewlett.
The Hewlett Foundation put
forward a big stream of money
around deeper learning.
Of course, he who has
the gold makes the rules
and gets to name, sort of the
new version of the Golden Rule.
And they say that
deeper learning
entails mastering core academic
content, critical thinking
and problem solving,
collaboration,
and self-directed learning.
Less formally, I
would just think of it
as being able to see beyond
the surface of an issue
and being able to
understand its deeper roots.
So we're going to talk
a lot more about this.
I just wanted to give you a
definition just to get started.
OK.
So why should we
care about this?
The most often-cited
reason is economic.
That 50 years ago
you could graduate
with a mediocre high
school education,
get a job at the
factory down the road
if you were a
white man, and that
would lead to a
decent middle-class
income with which you could
buy a house where you could
put your 2 and 1/2
kids and reproduce
to the next generation.
That's obviously
no longer possible.
If you asked
employers in 1970 what
the top skills they wanted,
they would say reading, writing,
and arithmetic.
If you ask them
today, they say things
like teamwork, problem
spotting instead
of problem solving-- like,
can you identify problems?
So the economy, the requirements
of the economy have increased.
Second reason is equity.
So to the degree that this
learning already exists,
it's mostly existed in elite
publics and in privates.
The Lab School in Chicago--
the school Dewey founded--
at one point their slogan
was "21st century skills
since the 19th century."
So what I'm talking
about is not exactly new,
but the demand for lots of
people to be able to do it
is new.
And in particular the
idea that all students,
particularly students of color
and high-poverty students,
would have access
to this as new.
And if that doesn't
convince you,
there's always this sort
of societal rationale.
I first made this slide
before the election,
arguing that people's
ability to be discerning
in their choice of
political candidates
and being able to read
statistics, decipher
evidence, penetrate
real news and fake news
was really important.
And nothing since the
election has shaken me
of the importance of that view.
As my dad said to
me once, you think
that you're sort of trying to
solve poverty and mobility,
but really the fate of
the country is at stake.
And I think that there's
some truth to that.
And then the last point is just
interpersonal contexts are also
very complicated.
I pulled this photo
from the internet.
Looks like a nice Latino family.
Who knows what dark secrets
are lurking below the surface?
I'll just give one example.
In my house, my
older son is six.
And I wanted him to pick up
stuff when he messes things up,
and in my mind this was
sort of Kantian duty.
Like, if you create the problem
you should fix the problem.
And I tried to explain
to him that living
in a communal society
meant that you had
to take your part and so on.
And then I went
to work and I came
home and things were picked up.
And I said, what happened?
And he said, oh Grandmom,
his mother-in-law, paid me.
In dollars.
And I thought, oh.
And my wife's-- and my
mother-in-law does some portion
of our childcare-- and my
wife just looked at me,
and she's like,
don't rock the boat.
So, you know, as Judy said, I
have several advanced degrees
and have spent a lot
of time thinking.
And it really took every
ounce of all of that thinking
and ability to manage
emotions to try to figure out
sort of how to navigate
the situation, which might
be familiar to some of you.
All right.
So the challenge is there,
and the question is,
could schools do their part?
All this-- you know,
a lot of things
you learn for life you're going
to learn outside of school.
But could school do its
part in helping equip us?
So that's what I want
to talk about today.
What does it mean to
understand something deeply?
How do you teach
for deeper learning?
Why are these
experiences relatively
rare in American schools?
And what would it take
to build a system that
would more consistently
support good experiences?
In the teaching part, while
I'm talking about high schools,
a lot of it might be relevant
to university teaching.
So there may be things,
for those of you
who teach at that level,
that might be useful to you.
Definitely doing
this project has
helped me revise
some of the things
that I do in my own teaching.
OK.
Oh, and I should
also say that this
is going to be an interactive
talk, because there's no way
I can talk about deeper
learning and just
stand here and lecture
at you for 45 minutes.
So just be prepared
that you're going to do
a little bit of mental work.
OK.
So what does it mean to
understand something deeply?
Let's think about this
together a little bit.
OK.
So this is a cell.
You may remember this from
middle school or high school
biology.
How many people in here
have significant experience
with biology?
All right.
So more than in a public
audience, but still most of us,
this doesn't look too
familiar, myself included.
OK.
So you don't need to know a
lot about biology to play.
If you don't remember
all the parts of the cell
you can just sort of make it up.
For the moment.
For the moment I'm
going to talk about why
that's a bad idea in
schools and all of that.
All right.
So here's I want you to do.
So imagine that
you were a teacher,
and imagine that you
were trying to design
a deep lesson around the cell.
Anybody can do a deep
lesson around oral history
of the civil rights movement.
Like, the material
just writes itself.
But let's say that you needed
to do it around this cell.
You wanted students
to sort of understand
some key aspects of the cell.
So just take a minute
or two, and then confer
with a person or two around you.
And try to tell
each other what you
would do if you were trying to
teach deeply about this cell.
OK, go for it.
[AUDIENCE CHATTER]
All right.
OK.
So who has an idea.
Let's start first
with the folks who
don't do biology for a living.
Or don't have-- just
folks who are just
treating this sort of
from a lay perspective.
Give us an idea.
Go for it.
- Make a story out of it.
Say, what is the
cell trying to do?
How are these parts
going to help do it?
And also, my brother
was a biology professor,
and if he had to talk on this,
he did not give a handout.
He put it on the board
and they had to copy it
into their notebooks.
And he said they learned
it better that way.
- All right.
So there were two ideas there.
One, if they copied it
they would remember it.
And two, if they needed
to know something
about what the cell
did, that would
help them make sense of it.
OK.
- Our idea was to have groups
of them, each sort of--
if you think about
it as a system,
each person remove a
piece of the system.
And then play out [INAUDIBLE].
- Why-- tell us more about
why you hit on that idea.
- Because it would help them
understand how each piece
functioned within the cell.
And in every case, each
piece is necessary.
So if you take one out,
the cell will likely
die but in a different way.
- Hm.
Interesting.
Other ideas.
Go ahead.
- There's one word that occurs
twice, and that's membrane.
So I think it must be important.
[LAUGHTER]
It must be important
[INAUDIBLE].
For keeping in as a barrier.
Keeping out some things,
letting other things go in.
Mode to the cell as a whole.
And the other place it
occurs is around the nucleus,
and I have no idea why--
what's special
about the nucleus.
[INAUDIBLE]
But membrane, obviously, has
to have it's own membrane.
- Huh.
So that's interesting, right?
Even without detailed
biological knowledge,
you can reason just from what's
written on the slides, right?
You can start to understand
something about the functions
just by noticing that two of
the things share the same term
and thus must be
playing the same role.
OK.
One more.
Stephanie, go ahead.
- I was thinking
when you were talking
about the possibility
of showing the cell
under some sort of duress.
So the cell affected by some
kind of disease, infection,
would the functioning
be different?
Would the story be different?
- So sort of the Garfinkle,
ethnomethodological approach.
Like, if you put
it under stress,
you'll get some sense of why it
works and why it doesn't work.
All right.
So those are great ideas.
And the reason that they're
great ideas and a number of you
hit on them, is
that they don't just
ask you to think about
what the parts are.
They ask you to think about
how the system functions.
And another way that
you could do it is you
could ask them to
make an analogy.
So, say, to sort
of create a city
and have the city
serve out-- have
the parts of the city do the
same functions of the cell.
And if you can transfer
the principles of what's
happening in the cell
to another context,
that demonstrates that you
understand how they work.
All right.
OK, good.
Oh, and I should say that this
is too cultured an audience.
Sometimes people say
things like, well,
what if you just made
every kid-- like,
gave every kid a role,
and one dressed up
as the nucleus and one
dressed up, and so forth.
And they're like, you know,
it would be really engaging.
And it might be
engaging, depending
on how you pitched it.
But it wouldn't get
at the function.
So about a sixth of
us are biologists.
How many people have
listened to "Car Talk"?
Aha.
OK.
All right.
This is my kind of crowd.
OK.
So if you--
I think the "Car Talk"
really brings it home, right?
So when someone calls
"Car Talk" and they say,
my thing is my car
sputters every 50 feet
and then it shuts down,
and it makes these sounds.
[SQUEAKING SOUND]
And then the guys are like, does
that happen more when it rains?
There you see someone
who understands
the symptoms talking to someone
who understands the underlying
system.
And so the questions are from
a diagnostic point of view
from the perspective of someone
who understands the system.
OK.
So this is the cognitive
side of deeper learning.
It connects to research on
expertise, pattern recognition.
And one way of looking at
the cognitive side of deeper
learning in the classroom
is to use a very old tool,
Bloom's Revised Taxonomy,
which was created in the '50s.
And anyone who's taught
is familiar with this.
Basically distinguishes six
levels of classroom tasks--
remembering, understanding,
applying, analyzing,
evaluating, and creating.
And so when we went into
classrooms, just very simply,
we just said, what
are the kids doing?
And which level
across these things
are they-- what are
they being asked to do?
So if they're copying
something from the board,
they're remembering and maybe
potentially understanding.
For example, if they're
applying an algorithm in math--
so they've been
given the algorithm.
They're working
out the problems.
That's applying.
And then analyzing,
evaluating, and creating
is more sophisticated.
So the Gates Measures
of Effective Teaching
study classified tasks this way.
This is the largest
ever study of--
videotape study of classrooms
in the United States.
And they found that about
four in five classrooms
were in this bottom half.
And about one in five classrooms
were in this top half.
And that was pretty
consistent with our experience
going into classrooms.
Another way to put it is,
if I stapled myself to a kid
and followed that kid
through their day,
we would likely hit upon
one, and sometimes two,
classrooms where teachers
were asking students to think,
to put it in really
simple terms.
There were sort of good news
and bad news in our study
in that a number of the
schools that we went to
were recommended schools.
So Someone said,
if you really want
to understand deeper
learning, 21st century skills,
go to this school.
And the bad news was
that in those schools
there was often much
less than met the eye.
What was on the web site
far outran what was actually
happening in the classroom.
The good news was, just
in regular public schools
down the street, this one
in five pattern prevailed.
So I gave a talk once somewhere,
and I was talking about one
in five, and I was
putting it out there
as a sort of fairly
pessimistic number.
And someone came up to
me afterwards and said,
if there's 3 and 1/2
million teachers in America
and 700,000 of them
are doing this,
then you have a really large
group of people who are already
doing the things that you want.
Couldn't you build on that?
And so that was interesting.
OK.
So then the second part is the
sort of affective dimension,
right?
Which is like, why
would anyone want
to learn about the cell
in the first place?
Those of us who are my age-- who
are sort of sandwich generation
folks who have parents and
aunts and uncles who are getting
older--
all of a sudden
biology is becoming
a lot more interesting,
because people
are getting sick in
a variety of ways
and sort of understanding
how the body can break down
seems a lot more relevant than
it did even a few years ago,
say for me.
So the question is, what's
the purpose of the learning.
And so the other thing that
we looked for in classrooms
was engagement, which is,
were kids watching the clock,
waiting for the class to end?
Were they full-throated involved
in whatever was happening?
And so here's a quote from
a teacher about her best
classroom.
This was actually one
of these really strict,
no excuses schools.
And we said, so what
happens on your best day?
And she says, I mean
there's just a feeling.
Kind of a buzz or a sense of
investment and engagement.
It's really hard to quantify
that and describe it,
because it's kind of an
aura that fills the room.
So I feel like my best day
is when everyone is not just
focused-- because I think
our kids are always focused
because they have
to be focused--
but invested in what
they're learning.
That there's something
motivating them beyond just
that they have to do this.
They're experiencing a level
of intellectual engagement,
even if English is not their
favorite subject or one
that they feel
particularly good at.
But they feel the lesson
is exciting and worthy
of their mental space.
So all of us have
taught, and all of us
have had classes that have
taken off, and all of us
have had classes that fall flat.
So there's no world where
every class is going to soar.
But the question is, could you
create the elements that would
make them soar more often?
And can you get to the
center of the Venn diagram?
All right.
So here's some national
data from the student Gallup
poll on engagement.
This is actually a
composite of a number
of more specific indicators that
measure engagement in school.
And fifth graders, about
75%, say that they--
so self-report--
75% say that they're
engaged in school.
And by 12th grade it's
down to about 32%.
And you have to be in
school to take this poll.
So all the kids
who are dropped out
are not represented
in this sample.
And presumably the most
disengaged kids aren't there.
So the real numbers
are actually worse.
And I would challenge you
to think about engagement,
not as a sort of
frilly side effect,
like oh they're adolescents.
They're bored.
Adolescents always
say they're bored.
But to think of it more like
a precondition for learning.
That until you
engage in a subject
you can't really take it up.
So long story short,
our tour of schools
convinced us that there are
sort of two big challenges
facing American schooling.
One is about the
level of challenge,
and the other is about
the level of engagement.
And if we could make some
progress on those two things,
our students would have--
there would be much less wasted
potential in
schools, and we would
have much more capable adults.
All right.
So just to sort of
illustrate this,
just wanted to talk
about two classes
from an affluent public
high school in New England.
This is a picture of
Wayland public high school.
That wasn't the
school in our study,
but it just gives you a sense.
This is not a school where
everything's breaking down,
where there's no money, where
the teachers have no experience
level.
This is the kind
of place where you
would pay money for a house to
send your kids to this school.
And so kind of the
average class--
OK, so again, this is
not a disastrous class.
This is not kids--
as a book on schools
opens with kids
peeing into the plant
in the classroom.
It's not it's not like that.
This is just sort
of normal school.
OK.
So the teacher's
standing in front
of the class, AP
psychology class,
reviewing for an upcoming
unit test on different types
of conditioning.
What is overjustification,
she asks.
And Eliza says,
people do things when
they expect to get the reward.
What is food aversion, she asks?
Adam says, if you
eat something that
makes you feel sick you
won't want to eat it.
She reminds them of an
acronym that Mr. Chen,
another psychology
teacher, came up with.
V.O.I.C.E.-- voluntary,
operant, involuntary, classical.
But it's a bad acronym,
because the E doesn't
stand for anything, she says.
The kids laugh.
She gives a few minutes in small
groups to talk about the terms
they are unsure about.
She passes out an
open note quiz.
The questions are
pretty similar.
Like, what is stimulus response?
They go through the answers.
She asks students to
volunteer the answers.
She says, Connie, what
did you get on this?
And Connie says A, and
she says, that wouldn't
be the best choice.
And she turns to someone
else, and they say B,
and she says yes,
that is correct.
And after that she gives
them some advice about what
the AP is looking for on their
short answers, and then class
is dismissed.
So this is kind of average.
Not terrible, not incompetently
managed, but just sort
of average.
And then compare this to another
class in the same school.
So Philosophy as
Literature class.
This is an elective class, which
is important in that students
had chosen to take this class.
And when I come in, they're
sitting in a sort of semicircle
and they're
discussing Descartes.
And they're discussing this
idea about, is the fact
that we know--
how do we know what we know?
Does the fact that I could
think that everything out here,
you all could be a dream.
This podium could be a dream.
These chairs could be a dream.
But the fact that I'm thinking
it means that I exist, right?
And so they're sort of unpacking
this idea from Descartes.
The students are doing
most of the talking.
Mike is interjecting
things occasionally.
And then the students
are saying things like,
what about computers?
Computers seem to
think, but do they
exist in the same
sense as humans?
Or what about vegetables?
Like humans as vegetables.
They can't think,
but don't they exist?
And so the class just sort
of went around like this.
Pondering different examples
and counter-examples
and trying to think about,
what would Descartes
have made of that?
What would they have
made of Descartes?
And then towards
the end, the teacher
tries to do this teacherly
thing of saying, all right, well
tomorrow we're going to
talk about how Descartes--
Descartes' views on God
and why God must exist.
And the students are
like, wait, wait.
How would he know that?
And what's the logic?
And where is it coming from?
And he's just trying
to wrap up the class.
But once you let
out of skepticism
you can't bottle it back up.
One of the students
in that class
told us that he had tried to
explain what Descartes thought
about free will to his carpool.
So I that that's
kind of how it went.
And so part of the
question is how could we--
what's different about
these two classes,
and how could we generate
more of the second and less
of the first?
And as we started to look
across these teachers,
we noticed some differences
between most teachers
and what we might call these
sort of deeper learning
teachers.
The first point
was just the goal.
That the goal of most teachers
was to cover the material.
And the goal of these teachers--
if you really sort of
put a point on it--
they were trying to
basically inspire people
to become members of a field.
They knew that understanding
Descartes would
take a long time,
many years of study,
but what they were
just trying to do
was just get kids to begin
the practice of arguing
and thinking in
philosophical terms.
Because of that, their
pedagogical priorities
focused on depth as
opposed to breadth.
Their view of knowledge was
uncertain rather than certain,
right?
That knowledge, even
disciplinary knowledge,
is essentially provisional.
It's an interpretation
created by a group of scholars
and verified through
certain conventions.
And they were inviting
students into that,
and they were
essentially helping
students play with that.
You could see that again
in the Descartes example.
Like, what the students
did is this sort
of rudimentary version of what
philosophers would do around
the same question.
Change the role of student
from a receiver of knowledge
to a creator of knowledge.
They had a different
view of failure,
not as something to be
avoided but as something
to be embraced.
And these classes had
a different ethos.
Less compliance, more what
I call purpose plus play.
OK.
So what differentiated
these people?
A big part of it
was their stance.
So they had a
different view of what
it is they were trying to do.
A second part was
their knowledge.
They were deeply knowledgeable
about their fields
and thus were not afraid of
venturing into places where
they might not know the answer.
They welcomed
students saying things
that they hadn't
thought of, and that
came from a certain
security with the content.
They developed pedagogical
skill in a particular mode.
The mode might vary.
In Mike's case it was sort of
leading a Socratic seminar.
In another case it
might be project-based.
In a third case it might
be competency-based.
At the university-level
and might be case teaching.
The mode didn't
matter, but they had
developed enough
sophistication with the mode
that they sort of
knew how to use it.
And then critically they'd had
experiences of what it was they
were trying to create.
So whether those experiences
had happened in their own K-12
schooling, in higher ed,
or somewhere along the way,
as teachers, they'd
sort of become convinced
that the way that people
normally do education
wasn't really serving
their students well
and that they wanted to
do something different.
There was one woman
in our study who
taught a fabulous Theory of
Knowledge philosophy class
where the students
said, this class
makes my brain hurt every day.
And I said, where did you
learn to teach like that?
And she's like oh
well the first time
I started teaching was on
a Fulbright in Indonesia.
And October of the first year
this student came up to me
and tapped me on the
shoulder and said,
you seem like a
really nice lady,
but you've got to stop talking.
And she just sort of saw that
as a signal moment, which
had started-- she
was probably 45
when I talked to her-- but this
had started a long journey.
Most of the teachers who are
in our deeper teacher sample
were over 35.
It took a while to
get to this place.
OK.
So I want to switch
gears for a second.
And I want to think
a little bit about,
how do people become deeply
knowledgeable about something?
Because you might think
that how people become
knowledgeable or
skilled at something
should inform how we think
about what happens in schools.
Call me crazy.
So just think of a domain--
could be a professional
domain, could be a hobby,
could be cooking, could
be whatever it might be--
where someone could
come to you, and they
could ask you a question.
And they could ask you
a follow-up question,
and you would feel comfortable
having a really significant
conversation about it.
OK.
You got something
like that in mind?
All right.
And now try to
think a little bit
about how you came to reach that
level of skill or expertise.
Were there signal events?
Did it happen in
formal schooling?
Outside of schooling?
Et cetera.
OK.
So just turn to a neighbor
and take a couple minutes
and exchange stories.
We've got about four minutes,
so take about two minutes
and then swap.
Go for it.
[CHATTER]
All right.
All right, great.
One of the perils of
student center teaching
is that people never want to
return to the person up front.
OK.
So who has a story that
they want to share with us?
Go for it.
- My question is, can we ever
be knowledgeable [INAUDIBLE].
There's the saying that
says, I know one thing--
that I know nothing.
I was just telling my neighbor
that yes, I studied something,
I learned things.
But then the field
itself develops.
And as time goes by I find
myself genuinely knowing less.
- Interesting.
All right.
Let's pick that up
at the questions.
That seems like--
- We could make a loaf of bread.
- What's that?
We pose that as a question when
we get to that, the questions.
Anybody have a story
they want to share?
Or would people like to let
me talk with you for a minute
or two about your skill?
Kristen.
- So mine is vegetarian cooking.
- Vegetarian cooking.
OK.
How did that start?
Like, were you--
- So I think it started
that I became a vegetarian
in high school, and
my family was like,
well you're going to
cook your own food.
And then realizing that I didn't
know anything about protein
or anything like that.
And it took me a long time.
So I read a lot of magazines and
books and just practiced a lot.
Trial and error.
Made love terrible meals.
Ate a lot of salads until I
couldn't eat salads anymore.
Really learned to cook
more through that.
- What motivated you
to become a vegetarian?
- She knew she'll meet me.
- That's right.
- You're really sitting
in the right spot today.
- I had an older sister
who had gone to college
and become a radical
feminist and a vegetarian,
and so she send me the book,
The Sexual Politics of Meat.
- Aha.
[LAUGHTER]
- [INAUDIBLE]
- Yeah.
And I think it was sort
of shared opposition
to Thanksgiving
with their family
to be like, we're
not eating this.
- Is there any
community in your story?
Did you ever find other
people who knew how to do it?
- Yeah.
And I think that I've
gotten better by--
like, I just think
I like to cook
with other people, particularly
other vegetarians or vegans.
And so that's something
that I do together a lot
in learning different kinds
of techniques and things
like that.
- Does anybody
have a second story
which is different, not just in
subject but in kind, somehow?
Nick.
- I'm a master-ranked
chess player.
I got strong by playing
[INAUDIBLE] games
and getting beaten.
I did a lot.
And I didn't like it one bit.
So I work hard.
[INAUDIBLE] and then you go up
a level and I got beaten again.
- All right.
Anybody have any
example of something
that's not so much a
skill, but a development,
a way of thinking,
a way of being.
- So my mom's an
education degree holder.
And when we were
growing up-- and I'm
the oldest in my
family-- she would often
talk about why she was
parenting in certain ways
because of what kids do at
that developmental stage.
Or explain what she was
doing as she was doing it.
And I think she also was reader
of a great deal of fiction.
So there was was always kind
of a third person omniscient
narrator going on in my house.
It made me fear of the
"why" of dealing with kids.
And it made me more
willing to then--
as I got older and was
babysitting and then
being other roles with kids
and eventually parenting--
asking other people
who I saw having
really good
relationships with kids,
where kids would have a
lot of fun and learn a lot,
why are you doing that?
Or what makes you do that?
- That's interesting.
So it's sort of--
normally when there's
parenting, there's
just the parent and the kid.
In this case, there was
the parent and the kid
and there was this sort of body
of thinking about parenting
that was in the conversation
between the three of you.
And that sort of
sparked an interest
and as you became a parent,
especially, or a child
caretaker, you continued to--
OK.
All right.
So I would love to
continue to do this,
but maybe we can return
to it in the questions.
So we think that
there's a model that
roughly captures some
of the kinds of things
that you all said.
It has three elements-- mastery,
identity, and creativity.
So mastery is developing
knowledge and skill
and a domain.
So in chess that would be
learning the openings and--
And then there's an
identity dimension.
It comes to matter to you.
We heard that in
Kristen's example
of the sexual politics of meat.
And then there's a
creativity example,
where you're not just
taking in things,
you're trying to do things.
And how well you
do those things--
we heard this in
Nick's example--
particularly when you're unable
to do the things that you wish
that you could do,
that pushes you back
towards the more
basic parts of study,
which is the mastery part.
Benjamin Bloom, the same guy who
came up with Bloom's Taxonomy
did a study of swimmers--
Olympians and other
national swimmers-- and he
asked them and their parents how
they'd gotten to be that way.
And they said,
well, when we were
four we just liked the water.
We liked to play in the
pool and at the beach--
the water was our thing.
And then we got some
coaching from our local Y
and so on and so forth.
And somewhere between 8
and 12 there was a shift.
We went from I'm someone
who swims, to I'm a swimmer.
And then when that
identity shift happened,
that motivated a
lot of practice.
So this is all
that stuff you hear
about discipline, practice,
repetition, and all that.
There was a lot of that
between about 12 and 20.
The coaching got
more sophisticated.
So they went from the Y to
the state to the national.
So they were getting
more and better feedback.
And then they said at the end
they could play again, just
at a much more sophisticated
level than they could before.
So you might think of these
cycles of mastery and identity
and creativity as a spiral.
That over time, you do
this in communities.
And over time, each
community shapes you,
including Radcliffe.
And the attributes of
that community move you,
and where you are
in your journey
when you hit that community
affects what you take of it.
OK.
All right.
So to tie this to bring
this back towards schools,
where are there opportunities
for deeper learning
in American schools?
And so we say we sort of
have three big observations
from our study.
One, in all schools
opportunities
for deeper learning were
present but relatively rare.
Two, the opportunities
that were there
were unequally distributed
by race, class, and track.
And three, that
peripheral spaces,
including electives
and extracurriculars,
were often more
promising platforms
for this kind of learning
than disciplinary classes.
So in the remainder
of my time I want
to talk a little bit about
each of those three points.
All right.
So the first point is that the
"Grammar" of Schooling, which
is a term developed
by my colleagues
David Tack and Larry Cuban, to
describe the sort of aspects
of schooling that are
so baked into schooling
that we don't even really
think about them being there
but have really significant
impacts in what happens
with respect to learning.
So I was particularly
interested in high schools.
In most of the
high schools I went
to kids were taking seven things
for 45 to 50 minutes each.
Teachers said that basically
it took a few minutes
to get going.
About the point where people
were starting to get interested
in things you had
to shut it down
if people were going
to wrap up their papers
and move on to the next thing.
Kids said they were trying to
do homework in seven things
each night.
And so if you were trying to
design opportunities for people
to do things in depth you
wouldn't do it that way.
The second point is
breadth over depth.
The state standards and
the district pacing guides
emphasized, must
cover this thing
that Newton did, this
thing that Darwin
found, this play that
Shakespeare wrote, et cetera.
And that the march of
content and the pace
made it hard to go into depth.
The core test for
students in school
is to record what other people
have thought about things
and reflect that back.
They have a lot of
practice at that.
They do not have
a lot of practice
at creating knowledge or
thinking about where knowledge
comes from, which is why
I think that often they're
doing what you might think of as
facsimiles of disciplinary work
rather than actual
disciplinary work.
So in science, for
example, when you do a lab,
you're essentially
following a series of steps
to show to yourself a principle
that somebody else has already
discovered.
And if the lab
doesn't show that,
then you did something wrong.
Like, something went
wrong in your lab.
Whereas science, as
everybody in this room knows,
is basically the
opposite of that.
You're not showing
yourself the known,
you're exploring the unknown.
There's little connection
to the outside world,
and students did few things
that didn't just go to teachers
and come back.
So the grammar was
sort of not promising.
All right.
A second point.
So I just want to
tell you about a day
we spent at a traditional
public school in the Bronx.
This was a high-poverty
school and had
all the problems
you might associated
with a high-poverty school.
And my colleague and I,
Sarah, spent the morning
at the school.
And I went to a
history class, and it
was one of the--
it was literally
one of the worst classes
we saw in our whole study.
The students were
sitting in rows.
The teacher was saying, and
then the Industrial Revolution
happened in--
and the kids were supposed to
say, 1900, 1880, like that.
And so that was my morning.
I came to lunch rather dejected.
My colleague Sarah, with
whom I've done a lot of work,
also saw history classes
in this same school,
and in the classes
that she saw, kids
were examining
primary documents,
developing
interpretations, giving
each other feedback on each
other's interpretations.
You know, they were doing
a sort of 11th grade
version of history.
And so we come to
lunch and we're
reporting our various
mornings, and we're
sitting in this conference
room, and this woman walks in,
and we realize that we've seen
the same woman teach, just
in different tracks.
And she said-- we talked
to her, and she said, well,
I tried to do this stuff
with these kids last year.
And it didn't really take, and
they need to pass the Regents.
And for Regents
they need to know
when the Industrial
Revolution is,
so this year I'm
doing it this way.
So there's a big gap
in the field when
it comes to knowledge of
how to interest and engage
students who are not in the top
tracks in this kind of work.
We tend to sort of
blame the people,
but I would sort of
tend to blame the field.
They have ways of working
in certain contexts,
but they don't know how
to work in other contexts.
There were some
people in our study
who did it with students who
are not in the top track.
And there's lots of people
in other people's studies
that have done that.
So it's not that
it's not possible,
it's just that the
knowledge of how to do that
is not widely available.
There's also a belief gap.
Teachers in more
affluent settings
had much higher beliefs about
what their students could do
and that shared racial and class
backgrounds in those schools
had them treat students as sort
of capable, meaning makers.
The famous line about this is,
upper/middle class students are
being prepared to
manage factories,
and poor and working
class students
are being taught to
work in factories.
And that's a very old
line of the literature,
but it's still true.
OK.
So basically we saw
different kinds of challenges
to deeper learning across
these different contexts.
So I've talked
about the challenges
for the poor and the
lower track students,
but I want to take
a minute to talk
about the challenges in the
middle and upper track classes.
So in the AP track
classes, among students
who are trying to get into
top and selective colleges,
there was a different kind
of problem, which was--
scholars in education
have distinguished
between what they call
performance and learning
orientations.
Performance-- some
of you may know this,
because it's sort of
filtered into the higher ed
how we should be
teaching literature--
but performance
orientations emphasize
getting the right answer.
Learning orientations
emphasize productive, struggle,
exploring, making
mistakes, et cetera.
And students,
particularly students
who wanted to-- who lived
in affluent communities
and wanted to go
to top colleges,
they were not having any of
this learning orientation.
They wanted to
know that they were
going to get the good grade.
They wanted to know that they
were going to get the AP.
The teachers were in turn
evaluated by the parents,
on the grades, by the
community, on the number of APs
the kids passed.
And so all of this mitigated
against more powerful learning.
In these communities teachers
frequently said, you know,
we do a lot of the interesting
stuff basically from now,
this point in the
year-- like May 15th--
to June 15, because that's
after the APs are over.
This is a pretty
complicated issue,
because AP is a way to
create some standardization
across a lot of schools.
And so the same
teacher said, well, I
think AP might be a good
thing in another district
where they didn't have as high
expectations as we had here.
But anyway.
This performance versus
learning orientation thing
was a big problem.
This is a talk which is
covering a lot of ground,
so AP is a complicated subject.
There's variants across the APs.
History is the worst in terms
of depth versus breadth.
Other subjects, they've
made some changes.
We can talk about that
in the discussion.
Then there was this question
of the periphery and core.
So when we started the study
we were focused on classes.
That's what people
at ed schools do.
They study English,
math, biology.
And as we went to the
schools, we came to think,
this isn't really
where the action is.
The places where kids
are building skills,
where they're engaged, where
they're making mistakes,
look more like those
spaces around the edge--
choir, robotics club,
field hockey, debate--
then they do the core classes.
So here was one day
in the same school.
So this has me walking
into an English class.
Students are Googling-- and
this is pretty well-off school--
which country has the
highest voting rates.
Turns out to be some
country in Eastern Europe.
Who knew.
Then four minutes on me.
I'm a Harvard
professor, Harvard blah.
Anything to not do whatever
we're supposed to be doing.
Just provide some entertainment.
Then video clips from
three versions of Hamlet--
the Kenneth Branagh one, the
Mel Gibson one, and one other.
And then they were
supposed to be
doing some sort of
discussion of the clips
and how he was
portraying the character,
but there was only about
four minutes for that.
And then there was
this matching game
where they'd translated some
of the Shakespearean English
into modern English,
and they were
supposed to sort of order
it in the same direction
as the passages.
And then there was
homework and exit music.
And it turned out this was
actually a hip-hop elective,
but all seniors
had to read Hamlet,
and so it was like Hamlet
in a hip-hop elective.
So in theory they were supposed
to be emphasizing the identity
elements of Hamlet and so on.
Anyway, you can see what
it was actually like.
Anyway, so as I was
leaving, this girl, Rose,
comes up to the teacher.
And she says, Mr.
G, I'm not going
to be able to do the
reading for Thursday.
And he says why not?
And she says, well I'm the
stage manager for "Servant
of Two Masters," and we have
a show going up next week,
and I'm going to be here
till 11:00 every night.
So I don't have time to read it.
And he says, don't
worry about it.
You know what's important.
And so an hour
later, I'm sitting
in rehearsal for this show.
It's 3:30.
People are putting on costumes.
People are sitting
in small groups
running lines with each other.
They're socializing, bonding.
You know, they haven't
seen their friends all day.
Rose is there.
She has the stage
manager's notebook.
She's going through
the plan for the day.
Her demeanor is
totally different.
The director gathers the
troops, frames the day.
He says, forget your
quizzes, your tests.
It was almost like hypnosis.
Leave behind where you
were, and be present.
And then gradually move
from you to your character.
Re-envision yourself
as your character.
And then students lead
a physical warm-up.
So they warm up their mouths.
They warm up their bodies.
They're trying to
increase their energy.
And then there's rehearsal.
And students are rehearsing.
The students who are
rehearsing are onstage.
They get stopped occasionally
by the director for notes.
The students who are
not in particular scenes
are sitting in the audience
doing their homework,
on their phones, whatever.
But when they're
on stage they're
not doing their homework,
on their phones, et cetera.
OK.
So what's different
about the two spaces?
So here are eight elements.
One, there's a purposeful arc
towards public performance.
Two, they chose to be there.
Three, they're part
of a community.
Some of the students
said they didn't even
know the names of the
students in their classes
but that they definitely
knew the names of the people
in the show.
And the reason that
they knew that was they
were dependent upon
them, which brings us
to this next point about
inter-dependent roles.
So if normal classes have
one teacher and 30 students,
this had students in
every conceivable realm
of leadership.
One running the lights,
one running the costumes,
one running the set design.
And then-- those were
seniors-- and then juniors,
who are assistants to
all of those things.
Which created a lot
of opportunities
for apprenticeship learning.
There were these spirals
of mastery, identity,
and creativity. i.e.
They were developing
knowledge about their roles.
They were very invested
in what they were doing.
Over time, sweat shirts with
the show's name appeared.
And that sort of
marked them as having
collective identity, which they
started to wear around school.
Head, heart, and hands.
This is an old
Pestalozzi notion.
So in most of school it was
just sort of students' brains
on sticks.
They were only using the
cognitive part of their brain.
In this they were
emotionally invested,
trying to stretch who they were
to become their characters.
And that was quite
challenging, but also rewarding
when they succeeded.
And then finally, they were
doing what my colleague Dave
Perkins calls playing the
whole game at the junior level.
So Dave's idea is that
when little kids learn
to play baseball,
they don't spend
one year throwing and
the next year catching
and the year after that batting.
What they do is they
play baseball the way
that six-year-olds
can play baseball.
And sure, you practice the
elements to get better at them.
But you do it in the
context of the whole game.
So my six-year-old plays chess.
Not well, but we can work
on the specific pieces,
but he at least understands the
purpose of the overall thing
that he's doing.
And school often
compartmentalizes the purpose
of the overall enterprise
from the specific task.
OK.
So to wrap up, what
might we do about this?
So one agenda is a kind
of, within the box,
how can we improve things?
So if we didn't change
the fundamental grammar
of schooling, how could
we improve things?
And I think it would
look something like this.
We would need higher standards
for teachers, particularly
with respect to
content knowledge.
Because the content knowledge
is the basis from which
the rest of it flows.
Teacher training would need to
socialize and give experiences
to people that showed them
that teaching as transmission
wasn't really what
they were trying to do,
and showed them what a
different mode of working
would look like.
External testing would have to
shift from emphasizing coverage
to emphasizing depth.
This is not undoable.
International
baccalaureate is one system
of assessments that
measures things
with more emphasis on
depth than breadth.
So, for example, rather than
answering hundreds questions
about different things that
happened in American history,
you might write an essay
on a topic of your choosing
about things in
American history.
And that essay
might get evaluated
on level of argumentation,
use of supporting evidence,
things like that.
So you could change the
form of external assessment.
Symmetry.
As I said, we came to think
that you couldn't do this
unless you'd experienced it.
So we'd have to create
these experiences
for a lot of adults.
And we did see some
examples of success
beyond the individual
teachers and schools,
and these often
happened where there
was a sort of ongoing
effort to build
adult learning in the schools.
But I don't know.
The theater experience,
in particular,
made me think that even a
mediocre theater director was
working in a much more favorable
grammar than an average biology
teacher.
So sure, the quality
of the director
and what they could see and
the nature of their feedback
made a huge difference
in the quality
of the final production.
But a lot of the things
that they needed,
they didn't have
to persuade parents
that there was an authentic
performance to show up for.
They had long blocks
of time after school.
The idea of students had
seen shows in real life,
so they knew what they
were shooting for.
They had a lot to work from.
So, you know, what if
we re-imagined school
and we changed the
grammar of schooling
to follow the
grammar of learning?
And imagine that people got
put into vertically-- or people
chose to become part of
vertically integrated
communities of learning.
So, take something like
quantitative reasoning.
Everyone from my
six-year-old, who's asking,
why does this food hurt my
stomach and not that food?
We're talking about
correlation and causation
to my psychometric
colleagues at the ed school.
They're essentially
engaged in a common task
of quantitative
reasoning about social,
and in this case
biological, events.
But in school,
those opportunities
are very cut off
from one another.
So we can imagine a world
where 9th through 12th graders
enrolled in some sort of
quantitative reasoning
about the world class,
and ninth graders
are doing bivariate
correlations,
and the 12th graders
are doing regressions,
and the 9th graders get to see--
they're all reading
the newspaper
and seeing whether
the inferences that
are drawn commonly
really hold, which
might be interesting to them.
But they're doing it at
quite different levels
of sophistication.
Right now the 9th
grade students have
no access to what the 12th
grade students are doing
and vice versa.
All right.
So to conclude,
deeper learning is
hard to achieve but
worth striving for.
Once you move from black
and white to color,
it's hard to go back.
Just a question of
how we can help people
make that transition.